we're here with David Reynolds to talk
about his new book linking China that's
an interesting title
well I struggled for that title with my
publisher and I was thinking of American
revival I was thinking of young giant
but ultimately I came up with kind of a
hook to describe America emerging at
this period expanding gaining new
territory and defining itself through
the Monroe Monroe Doctrine and through
the Tyler Doctrine kind of on the world
scene as well and also coming up with
its first kind of giant president if you
want to call it that I mean Andrew
Jackson redefines the presidency so
waiting giant at the same time America's
growing industrial II a little bit still
agricultural of course but it's
beginning to urbanize and industrialize
so it really is a gaining stature on the
world scene for the first time which is
why I called a waking giant right well
you begin the book where we are the cast
of characters that is fascinating would
you like to talk about each one of them
and their role is waking the Giant well
in in my opinion the giant really first
awakened in a big sense with the Battle
of New Orleans I think that was such a
to me a transitional moment because here
Andrew Jackson defeated the British at
New Orleans and therefore well the war
of 1812 was virtually over anyway but he
in a sense ensured ensured that we get
the vast western territories there were
west of the Mississippi he drove back
the British and in a sense he opened up
the continent for the future and so
Andrew Jackson certainly certainly
stands out as at the very beginning of
that era there was obviously the
presidents of Monroe and John Quincy
Adams that preceded the election then of
Andrew Jackson in 1828 in 1832 and both
of those presidencies were very
portant for pot foreign policy in
particular I think there were also a lot
of there was also a lot of political
turmoil at that time so it was very
difficult for someone like John Quincy
Adams for example to get done what he
really wanted to do as president but
still a Secretary of State before that
and then afterwards as an anti-slavery
leader John Quincy Adams certainly was
very very important and this all set the
scene for the kind of backlash that
comes with with Andrew Jackson right
yeah and I always thought that the
battle is especially important to
Americans because we defeated a
professional army and something like
over 2000 British soldiers were killed
wounded or missing and the Americans
lost a dozen or so yes and Jackson
showed good strategy in that particular
battle he really did because he built
some ramparts and he hid behind them and
the British forgot to bring their
ladders to scale the rim parts and they
became kind of sitting ducks there this
was in Chalmette Louisiana as although
it's called the Battle of New Orleans
and it was such an inspirational victory
particularly because he had cobbled
together this kind of odd conglomeration
of troops not all of them very
professional and cobbled them together
and somehow they defeated this invading
professional army as you said very large
professional armies so it was just a an
incredible victory a symbolic victory
and in a sense it kind of puts America
on the map in a way that had he hadn't
quite been before that date and
nationalism as we know it really begins
with the end of the Battle of this is
this is when America for the first time
again to get back to the idea of waking
giant kind of wakes up to what
intrinsically was already there but it
kind of began to realize that hey we
really are a great country we're not a
second-rate power in the world at all we
can look at what Andrew Jackson did in
Nora
look at our incredibly fertile
territories out there all the resources
all the potential economic advancements
all of this and it comes really at the
end of war the war of 1812 this kind of
intense nationalism yes I have found
that prior to that time if you asked an
American who he was you might say I'm a
New Yorker or I'm a Virginian yes or I'm
a Pennsylvanian yes but after the battle
and with the development of nationalism
you were asking me you say I am an
American because he was proud of it
absolutely
and well it's very symbolic that it was
during at the end of the war of 1812
that Francis Scott Key wrote the Battle
Hymn of the Republic
yes the star-spangled banner' which is
now sung at all kinds of sports events
and everything it's it's it's such a
such an inspiring song about the bombs
bursting in air and the the flag proudly
waving in the air and really uh you know
focuses on that flag and a very symbolic
of the spirit the new spirit of that era
and the Americans were no longer British
or Colonials or Europeans they went now
very distinctly America absolutely this
is yes there were a few Southerners who
still believed so much in states rights
like Randolph and so forth that that
said I am loyal to Virginia Virginia is
my country but yeah that was kind of a
different you know uh in general I think
you're absolutely right that this there
was a collective sense of American being
an American and for the first time
really I'd say maybe between 1812 and
1820 is when that whole consciousness
begins to arise and the unique
characteristics of being an American
developed notice that they're no longer
wearing silk stockings no bridges
powdered wigs
they they have jackets and ties that's
right then and they look totally
different and they think frankly they
even lost their British accent if they
had one yes I think that's probably true
this was one a truly indigenous sense of
what America was I think Monroe is one
of the last people actually sometimes
wore the old-fashioned kind of uniform
in public but but then he didn't always
do that and and certainly it was an
incredible transition toward a much more
definable indigenous American
presentation of oneself one's language
absolutely
well the characteristics would you
ascribe to these people then that's
seriously any kinda proud of their
country independent entrepreneurial in a
good way someone materialistic at the
same time I would call them increasingly
religious there was an incredible
religious revival that was going on so
at the on one hand that wanted to earn
the almighty dollar and on the other
hand they were very interested in God as
well so it was kind of a combination of
the two they thought for themselves a
lot which was good and even at the same
time that they were very devoted to the
country they were they weren't afraid to
think individually and Angie Jackson in
a sense straddles that whole paradox of
being very individual and yet very
devoted to the common the Commonwealth
to the common American identity
you mentioned religion yeah now this
country has divorced the to which the
church and the state yes yet the
American people are an extremely
religious people how do you account for
that well I think what happened is that
when there was a separation of church
and state in America as a result of the
American Revolution it was basically a
Protestant country and Protestantism
itself believes in individual individual
definition of faith the end of
relation to God without too much priest
or Church or anything like that's it's
it's the individual in the Bible and the
individual in God and so when we had the
sudden separation of church and state in
America Protestantism in a sense hit the
fan and you get all these interesting
religious denominations arising this
period and variations on all different
kinds of Baptists and Methodists and you
get very heartfelt religion you get some
also you got some prophets people who
believe that they're chosen by God and
actually are being touched by God and
they themselves become cult leaders and
one of these prophets founds the Mormon
Church Joseph Smith who said that he
talked with an angel who allowed him to
write a Bible the Book of Mormon and so
it's a very very creative fertile period
in terms of religion and a lot of these
early Americans very very sincerely
turned to God turned to religion in a
very very deep essential way and when
they went to the revivals revivals were
increasingly important they became very
very emotional and sometimes they felt
that God actually touched them and it
would fall down and sometimes they'd
have to be dragged dragged away and
sometimes they've had so-called
religious exercises in which they
switched their heads and their whole
bodies would go into convulsions but
this was it sounds very theatrical but
it was very very earnest earnest for
them yes mrs. trollop went to one of
eight yes it was absolutely hard yes she
was disgusted yeah right thing yeah yeah
see people in a religious ecstasy that's
right if you're on the outside looking
in for some likenesses trollop this
British woman you know very akan prudish
British woman and she's looking at this
yes she was just horrified by what was
going and the people were howling and
wailing and screaming and everything but
for the people going through this this
was a genuine experience yes
if that is only one phase yes the Second
Great Awakening is it's called yes yes
what are the more important aspects of
that religious revival would you say
well I would say that what happens is
that yes you have that phase in that's
very very emotional and in a sense that
never completely dies away it dies out
but at the same time that becomes a
little more controlled in its
exhibitions over time and at the same
time it feeds into the reform movements
or movements of the 1830s and 40s
abolitionism transcendentalism
eventually women's rights
spiritualism various reform movements
that were very very important in the
1830s and 40s and so it becomes a
breeding ground actually for social
change this way that religion becomes a
breeding ground for social change indeed
yeah well there was some aspects of it
this period that they're not so
enlightening yeah would you comment on
on those well this was in a sense of
print Stila a rather young primitive
period in in some regards the medical
practices had not gone very far they
still believed in what was called heroic
medicine which is bleeding basically
they would cut open your vein and allow
vast amounts of blood to flow out of you
or their favorite medicine was calomel
which is a mercury compound and it was
made and largely out of mercury and that
could of course make you lose your teeth
and eventually could kill you eventually
but they thought it could help you at
the time mean yeah and they had all
kinds of nostrils and vegetable pills
and the precursors of snake oil that
kind of thing these kind of panaceas and
they were very very popular it's kind of
quack medicine so and a lot of
pseudo-scientists these were
pretended doctors who were going around
and like phrenology was a very very
important movement extremely important
and they believed that there were 37
so-called organs of the brain that each
of which controlled a specific emotion
and that you could read it by by feeling
the bumps on your head and if you found
that somebody had too strong a bump of a
motive in this which is sexual love that
that person had to really use the
willpower to make that bump go down and
try to try to work on that and then it
was mesmerism which was putting people
in a trance and looking into their
bodies and seeing diseases in there
and trying to spot diseases and then
using a mental power to try to get rid
of those diseases as well so there were
a lot of interesting movements yes
Jackson regularly complained every time
he became ill he had dysentery all
because of the bullets in his body the
first thing they would do is bleed him
yeah and he writes in one letter I think
he said they took against me he said 16
ounces of blood for a man of my age I
don't think I should give up I know well
what they did yes yes and he survived it
at drugstores often the medicine that
they sold there were live leeches that
yeah these blood sucking and you put
them all over your body
even in private parts or whatever didn't
really matter you put them there and
they would suck your blood yes and
anyway and when Rachel died his wife
died Jackson himself said
bleed her you know he hadn't realized
that she actually passed away yet so and
he and the doctor tried to bleed her but
on the only little drop of blood came he
was already deceased yes yes yes yes
yeah he never got over it
no no never very relationship never
incredible and they never got over that
and then they used that against him
would you come in during the elections
would you comment on well yeah I mean
basically
they had she had been previously married
and they had lived together Jackson and
Rachel had lived together for a couple
of years she III believe she mistakenly
believed that she got a legal divorce
but she did she didn't get a legal
divorce and so I think this was really
damaging I haven't heard at a bill of
divorcement yes from the legislature
that was the procedure you had to first
get a bill of divorcement then you went
into the court proved that she was
guilty of adultery yes so he got the
bill of divorcement and that's why they
thought well he'd go right through and
there'd be yes doctor they went off to
nachos exactly and later he said they
were married there yeah we have no
evidence yeah it's a little bit hazy I
like to believe that Jackson was on the
up and up on that but of course his
opponents said he was had lived in
adultery and the terrible and I think
this really damaged Rachel I think that
affected her health I really I really
believe so yes she was technically a
bigamist and yes yes she learned that
they were using this in the newspapers
she collapsed yes yes yes absolutely and
I and I quite agree with you that I
think you're contributed to her yet he
was always convinced of it yeah oh yeah
always totally and he was so devoted to
her even after her death he was a very
very devoted to her right and to her
memory was there anything else in that
the election let's say of 1824 that well
was not dated called proper yeah
political procedures well now in the
1828 election of course there's a lot of
mudslinging not only was the the charge
of bigamy against Jackson but there was
the coffin ham bill showing so many
coffins of people he had supposedly
killed so just a soldier yeah soldiers
right he'd also been involved in some
duels he had
killed a man in the duel but so they
tried to portray him as a murderer and
also his opponents tried to say at one
point that actually he was mulatto and
that his brother had been sold into
slavery there was one very muddy say and
that his mother was a prostitute his
mother was a prostitute yes yes brought
to this country to service yes it's just
amazing that amazing but the and also on
his side some of his followers not
Jackson himself as some of his followers
charged that John Quincy Adams had been
a so-called pimp in Russia that had
turned over this lady to the Czar a
Russian for sexual favors for political
favors you know and and that was untrue
as well you know but there was a lot of
very very nasty mudslinging and indeed
yeah
worse than anything we have today it
really was and I think that what
happened is that there was a certain
there is today a certain transparency
even though there's still a lot of mud
that is slung there's still a certain
transparency and a certain public
discussion of a lot of these things that
perhaps would preclude totally false
stories like that kind of coming to this
we still have stories yes but I I think
there's a little more transparency now
there's as bad as it gets right well
Jackson is elected despite the attacks
as president and you comment about just
what he did to change the presidency and
strengthen it would you care to comment
he for example strengthened the
presidency to a great degree house
because he used the veto power far more
actually he used more vetoes than all
presidents before him put together yes
so if you combine all previous
presidencies the veto more he really had
a will he also
symbolized the common people and the
assault on the common people against
established institutions particularly
the Bank of the United States he waged
war on Nicholas Biddle in the bank of
the United States which for him was a
money to corporation in centralized
power and he began that whole rhetoric
of class conflict class warfare on
behalf of the working people
this doesn't mean it was anti-capitalist
but it doesn't mean that he was anti
kind of centralized capitalistic
institutions such as a large banks and
so forth and so he very much in that
sense was the first people's president
to a great degree he was also the first
president born in a log cabin the first
one that was from the West well was then
the West Tennessee and the first one
from a non Gentry background the first
one that was not either part of the
Virginia dynasty or the New England
Federalist dynasty so he was a very
important element of change yeah in the
American presidency on the
constitutional question not only did he
veto more times than any of his
predecessors but his predecessors always
use the excuse of constitutionality of
the bill they did not think was
constitutional Jackson felt he had a
right to veto for any reason that he
thought was not in the public interest
that's right he was the first kind of
power president in that sense and
there's a famous cartoon of Andrew
Jackson of showing him his opponents
showing him as a kind of King King and
Ruth right and he's trying yeah he's
Rhodes and he's holding a scepter as a
crown and everything Andrew the first
Andrew the first absolutely yes and he's
trampling on the Constitution and yeah
that's the way they saw him right like
the founders thought that the Congress
would be the centerpiece of Parliament
Blackson really felt it needed a leader
right and he as president could use this
power to impose his will on the Congress
if you want something done you better
check with me because I will veto it
and you have the to override a veto is
next to impossible yeah absolutely and
he he readjusted the balance of powers
yeah he's just the balance of powers and
was very very important for doing that
that and in doing so he also by being
called a tyrant a king yes by his
opponents he in a sense gave rise to the
modern party system two-party system
because the Whig party rose up against
him and so then you had really two very
strong parties at that point the other
party being the Democrats yeah and then
eventually his party was the Democrats
and eventually it split between
Democrats and Republicans yes yes of
course now there were other men who made
a contribution I'm thinking of Henry
Clay for example yes what was his role
in all of this awakening yes
well Henry Clay was very important for
he was front from Kentucky senator and
he was not a politician of long standing
he always wanted to be president and
many people thought yeah many people
thought he would be president he was a
great week leader anti Jackson and he
defended in a sense defended the bank
and defended the moneyed interest and
defended the tariff and he represented
the more strictly capitalist a viewpoint
of that era and he also even though he
was a slave owner he was he assumed a
cont compromised view on slavery that
eventually led to the compromise of 1850
he became a great symbolic leader he was
Abraham Lincoln's Idol yeah for example
though ideal absolutely I think because
he was ultimately a compromised figure
someone who could see both sides of the
picture at the same time that he hoped
for the eventual abolition of slavery
although he as I said he owned slaves
himself but he was a great colonisation
as someone as Lincoln became someone who
wanted to actually deport African
Americans and some send them back to
Liberia so he was kind of a moderate
figure at that moment yes he was also
known as the great compromiser yes would
you comment on his role as a compromise
he was the one who was one of the
architects of the Missouri Compromise he
was and in particular he later worked
with the Webster on the compromise of
1850 he was one who really tried to
prevent slavery from tearing apart the
nation yes from tearing apart the nation
they knew it could they knew it could
absolutely and so he was very much I
mean some people criticized him as being
a straddler a struggler but for example
in the Mexican War he was ambivalent
about that because it meant taking over
a lot of western territory that would
then go to the slave south they were
become slave states these western states
and so he was ambivalent about that he
at the same time he really didn't want
to alienate the south he didn't want to
alienate the north he was very very much
a compromise figure so and you can see
where there was a need at that moment
for that kind of figure to try to patch
together this the slaveholding south and
they sometimes anti-slavery north he
said that compromise is an agreement
reached through mutual consent yes how
do you get mutual consent and he said
because you're not a loser and you're
not a winner nobody wins no
losers each side gets something at once
but in order to get there they have to
give something to the other side
otherwise you have constant conflict
that's right and that's right this is
something I think politicians even today
me to learn yes yes want to succeed in
providing the American public with the
things that are good for them it doesn't
needed then both sides need to come
together
absolutely and agree to recognize what
the other ones say calhoune always said
that the if south was treated unfairly
right from the beginning by the federal
government yeah
and all they were asking for was justice
y'all knew inequality yes and of course
that included the protection of their
slaves of course of course
unfortunately what was happening of
course is that in the south
slavery which by the founding fathers
was kind of frowned upon even though all
the founding fathers Muslim owned slaves
they thought that ultimately it should
go I'm Jefferson it would go it would
but then increasingly however with the
rise of the cotton industry and
everything slavery became very valuable
to the south and so there was a moral
ideological and economic yes investment
at the South had on slavery and that's
why it becomes more and more a divisive
issue yes during this period the
invention of the cotton gin absolutely
turning things around
absolutely and then where economics
began morality and religion followed and
suddenly you had all these southerners
saying oh the Bible supports slavery
because all the old testament right
prophets owned slaves and even the New
Testament there's not any real
denunciation of slavery and they go on
and on and on using all kinds of
rationalization which they hadn't in
previous not not no no no
not in the way they did only absolutely
God has four days yes good right exactly
I God is behind us yeah totally and and
Calhoun was the first to say slavery is
a positive good is something yes Father
but it's good for blacks it's good for
whites it's good for everybody same yeah
good afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts visit book tv.org more with
robert Remini and david reynolds in a
moment over the upcoming Christmas
holiday book TV brings you four days of
programming beginning at 8:00 a.m. on
Christmas morning read letters written
to first ladies over the years watched
Pulitzer Prize winning author David
Hackett Fischer discuss his newest book
Champlain stream here humorous Roy
Blount jr. on his latest book alphabet
juice and will also rear an in-depth
interview with historian Nell Irvin
painter you'll hear as well from Dave
berry and Frank McCourt and you'll see
some of our recent afterwords programs
featuring a Matisse lays on the Great
Depression and David Frost on his
interviews with President Nixon these
are just some of the programs you'll see
this Christmas holiday so join us this
Thursday morning for four days of book
TV on c-span 2 beginning at 8:00 a.m.
for the full schedule go to book TV org
and Happy Holidays afterwards with
Robert Remini and David Reynolds
continues we're back talking with mr.
Reynolds about his new book waking giant
America in the 8th during the age of
Jackson well we've been talking more
politics and some social history but we
need to think about the culture of the
period how was it different how was it
unique how was it magnificent I consider
this the rich richest cultural period in
American history because yes because we
had Ralph Waldo Emerson and
at the row nathaniel hawthorne the rise
of Herman Melville the rise of Walt
Whitman
he's just names I know they do they were
well the ones I've been mentioning are
wonderful writers these are literary
writers and Emerson is just our greatest
philosopher and Thoreau was both a
philosopher and a social reformer and
Melville was the author of Moby Dick and
the greatest American novel perhaps
Hawthorne The Scarlet Letter everybody
knows that and Edgar Allan Poe the
writer of all kinds of short stories and
it was an incredible period of literary
flowering yes and that's why we call it
the Renaissance of American literature
you know with Melville said about
Jackson yes yes about the great
Democratic God that took Andrew Jackson
from the pebbles and hurled him higher
than the throne yes and that was
wonderful
right he was that popular yeah oh
absolutely he had made for the American
consciousness a sense of the importance
of being an American absolutely yeah and
Jackson crystallized the kind of
combination of what's interesting about
Melville's saying that notice what he
says that God took them off the pebbles
the very low and threw him high than the
kind of paradox of the low and the high
the individual and the masses the kind
of combination that of the magnetic
individual on the one hand here and on
the other hand someone who represents
the masses and that whole swing between
individualism of the max masses is what
you get in Walt Whitman it's what you
get in Ralph Waldo Emerson it's what you
get in in Moby Dick
it's wonder with Jackson he was born a
poor orphan boy and he rose to the
highest office absolutely country only
in america only in america only in
america absolutely and when you think of
the writers
to think of Walt Whitman and just came
from a very lowly background right
his father was an alcoholic carpenter he
came from a poor background he didn't go
to school beyond the age of 11s Walt
Whitman and yet he rose and he think of
that
no Sulli no schooling and yet he's
second only to Shakespeare in a number
of words that he uses in his poetry yes
because there's something called self
education just reading I'm reading yes
yeah and he was in the newspaper
industry was always reading and writing
and thinking and there was something
very democratic about that too it's the
way a lot of these people taught
themselves and learned yes yes yeah and
Melville said a whaling ship was my Yale
and my Harvard you know well he just
went to see you went to see ya and yet
he's such a great terrific writer he's a
commonly our greatest poet yes yes
absolutely our greatest novelist and
poet deal absolutely wonderful do you
want to talk about some of the fads and
some of the curious phenomena of that
period well there was PT Barnum there
was a a real curiosity in that period
for what I call the esthe factor the
largest the smallest the heaviest you
know whatever the the loudest and PT
Barnum capitalized in this he assembled
curiosities things were there were
curiosities like a 60-pound man called
the living skeleton who could lift 250
pounds or 161 year old african-american
woman who was the quote nanny of George
Washington it turns out when she died
she was only 75 but that was okay and
these little midgets and the largest
elephant in the world and these
snow-white albinos from Brazil and Santa
Ana Santa Anas wooden like that was
captured in the Mexican War and all
kinds of curiosities they they loved
that kind of thing yes yes yeah
and they loved what we called model
artists and model artists where you go
when you pay twenty five cents and you
see a statue a living statue of a bunch
of figures a lot of them either nude or
semi-nude like Venus coming out of the
half-shell or Adam and Eve and they're
standing there stationary you know in
front of you and you just sit there and
you go oh my god they're amazing you
know and a lot of times there were
police raids on these because some of
them were nude a coral though Muslim had
a little drapes on them really but or
the Amazon women or something like that
that it was called the model art or
tableau vivant it has another name for
it there are a lot of funny fads back
then yes and yeah so you go from the
sublime to the ridiculous yes how then
would you characterize American culture
in this antebellum period the culture
the culture
yeah the general culture I mean we
talked about the sublime but really when
you think about the sublime in in people
like Melville and like Whitman and
Emerson there's some other kind of
exaggerated nonconformist bumptious gogo
spirit even in these great writers
Melville comes up with the largest
animal in the world
the white whale Whitman is compared to
some of Barnum's freaks because Walt
Whitman was such a poser or with his
beard and strange poetry and he said I'm
in love with my armpit odor and I kind
of think and there was something very
very and Thoreau who lived as a hermit
by Walden Pond and a little a cabin some
people thought that he was a kind of a
living curiosity so the sublime inand
and they kind of absurd in a sense came
together in this kind of energetic
individualistic and at the same time
kind of common
and forcefulness and a sense of
exaggeration you confidence confidence
yes yeah yeah do you think our culture
has declined from those from that great
period that's a good question I think
what has happened is that we still have
incredible energy in America we still
have and we still have a lot of
confidence which is great and we have a
lot of a kind of gogo and a hard work
but in a way it's been funneled it's
been kind of contained it's been kind of
institutionalized it's been turned it's
been in a way turned into formulas and
kind of it's not quite as freewheeling
back then they didn't have the the
institutions the corporations that are
like invisible presences in our lives or
not so invisible sometimes in a way
shaping what we do back then they didn't
have that really and so you had this
kind of freedom of expression that in a
sense we've we've lost today it has
they've been too much government then
did you say I think that what has
happened is that it's the inevitable
result of the rise of corporate culture
after the Civil War you had the rise of
corporations yes and the rise of kind of
a standardized mass culture along with
yes I think there has been in a sense
too much government I think that I'm not
saying we live in a police state or
anything like that but certainly the
government government back then was much
less intrusive in many ways than it is
today so I think that we have several
things kind of going on simultaneously
Jackson said that the government must be
an honest broker among classes that
there were greedy ambitious men who
would use the government for their own
ends
yes and the government must see to it
that it is honest in dealing with
everybody
yes equally yes and so he they had that
problem too and it can get out of have a
sink yeah cause all kinds of problems
such as he meltdown financially that has
occurred here towards the end of 2008
absolutely I think the there's a very
strong belief on the part of certain
thinkers Andrew Jackson Ralph Waldo
Emerson Henry David Thoreau many others
that the government could fall could by
becoming too large create corruption
pre-agreed right create oppression in
some way and that it really had to be
watched very carefully and that it had
to have a strong infusion of conscience
of moral conscience I am too often in
the society that we live in today we
lose a sense of that conscience that
sense of morality and because we're too
eager for either power or money material
goods and so forth
that that becomes the primary yes I've
always thought that the genius of
America can be seen in the many
inventions that we have produced that
not only help society and individuals
but then can be mass-produced and sold
to the world would you comment on this
period and what its record is in the
matter of the inventions of that period
were very startling for that time yes
they really were this was the time when
the railroad was invented and was first
put into use in around 1830 the
telegraph which was like a miracle at
that time sending signals over the wire
that was it came out in 1844 did there
get daguerreotype which was the early
photograph came over from France and was
very very popular to America and once
weren't popular here then
was abroad this was when the revolver
was invented by Colt this was on the
mechanical Reaper I came in vulcanized
rubber anesthesia came in at this period
even things like the stapler the sewing
machine came during the spirit steam
travel are vastly improved yesterday so
it was a time of great advance
technologically and more than that a
time in a belief in invention and a
belief yes in progress that America has
not let go of even to this very day
yeah the invention of anesthesia
I mean Jackson had to undergo an
operation to remove a bullet in his
shoulder with just holding on to this
was a walking stick gritting his teeth
that's right an enduring incredible pain
that's right
and here comes anesthesia I know them
they used to give you perhaps a little
whiskey or something like yes well that
yeah ha ha ha and say ok grab all of
this and grit your teeth you know that
anesthesia which was actually invented
almost accidentally because they used to
exhibit laughing gas is kind of a circus
show and they finally said oh well this
can be used you know for medical
purposes and I think it continues right
through our history even to this day
absolutely we show a peculiar and
particular genius for coming up with
ideas I think so I think it's one thing
that will save America perhaps who knows
you can't can't predict the future but I
think that inventiveness is that
imaginative nasir I really do and I
think it's something that will I hope
always be there yes and and so yeah I
think education has something to do with
it the fact that young men are
encouraged Yahoo
the individual and be free thinking and
try risk opportunities to him I don't
want to say anything bad about other
countries but I know that when I was
teaching at the Sorbonne for a year I
noticed my students I would ask them a
question in class and again I don't want
to generalize about yes all French
students but there wasn't that you know
they didn't come back with all these
kind of you know I they expected me to
give them the answer yes and I was
waiting for them to give me the answer
you know their answer which is what
happens in the American classroom you
ask a question quite often they'll come
back they won't just sit there passively
and just write this is what my teacher
is saying or like quite often especially
in a seminar situation will come and
they'll talk to you they'll talk with
you yeah and and they'll they'll express
their own ideas again I I suppose that's
just based on one little case history of
myself said I know if you feel the same
way I do yeah I think too often students
feel that you want your answer so I'll
just repeat what you said yes not say
but I think yes something else yes and
what's right or wrong with that exactly
and that is one of the real tasks and
education to get young people to think
them on their own that's right and if
you can encourage individualism
individual thought individual effort
education ultimately has to come from
oneself it can be elicited by the
outside information from the outside but
that outside then has to inspire
something within yourself yes so that it
becomes a driving force within you and I
think that that's the potential of
American education I think that we have
a good potential there I think we've had
it in the past I think we can still
develop that I think that there there is
a fertility of possibility in American
education that is not necessarily
resolved always by funding or so forth
it can be
help yes so what I'm saying is that
education definitely should go to try
somehow to elicit that own drive within
students that on the curiosity that is
part of that American heritage that you
and I were just talking about yes yes
yes yeah ambition yeah and absolute this
is how you gain the highest recognition
a social position that you would want
money of course is important sure we
tend to be very conscious of that sure
for many others it is that you have
contributed something to society you
have left your footprint on the sand of
time right and so that when you leave
this world there's some kind of record
of you there
and also when you're still in this world
you have some kind of a sense of
achievement right and some of them so of
having made a contribution and think of
all the great Americans along the way
who have done that one president of a
college slips my mind told the
graduating class you should die ashamed
if you've contributed nothing for the
welfare of humanity Wow
in that that's power Fame yes yes it
should be important that you lived yeah
yeah not that you just made money or had
a wife and children that's right but
that you've actually used your life
that's right Edda that's a big argument
in the Jacksonian period in the
Jacksonian period and the potential of
America is that in a way it really
doesn't matter what field you're in like
maybe some people oh I'm not in this
particular field therefore I can make a
contribution oh no no in a way it
doesn't matter what walk of life you're
in you can still make a contribution
solutely you can still make the
contribution advice it may not be that
other person's contributions but you can
you can make your own contribution and
that's so important I think that's what
in
by and so many people who join the Peace
Corps instilled yes I learn so much yes
go through the world that's right
helping other people the selflessness of
that incident is it's just just
incredible to me that that's a
tremendous contribution that that kind
of thing yeah but on the other side of
the coin yeah is the fact that we think
we know at all and that if you just be
like us you'll be prosperous you you
will have what we have yes this manifest
destiny do you want to talk about it
well that was the phrase that was coined
during this period of jacksonian america
in 1845 and it was at the time just at
the beginning of the Mexican War when
John Ellis Sullivan's democratic review
ran an article that said it is our
manifest destiny to spread westward and
to spread our values and by implication
to spread them even farther in the world
and this fed right into well eventually
fed into kind of the Bush Doctrine he
even mentions Providence
yes Providence has rule that the destiny
in this country is to spread its that's
right news that's right there are
freedom its institutions that's right
and and before that time it had been a
more of a passive model because Winthrop
of Puritan had said America is like a
city on a hill for all the world to see
but I was gonna pass it but now it was
very active we we should its are
destined that is spread to go today to
spread the blessing and that's that's
both good because we know what we have
is a good thing but it can then turn
around and be a bad thing as well you
know as John Quincy Adams said we must
not go around the world looking for
monsters to destroy absolutely will only
destroy our own freedom yeah yeah yeah
so and there was a warning
there were people back there and then
filibusters and even people in the
government who really wanted to take
over Cuba parts of
Central America parts of Latin America
there are even some people thinking
about Canada at that time so there were
a lot of real expansionists absolutely
at that moment you know dreaming about
spreading this manifest destiny yeah and
and with the spanish-american war
yes took the Philippines what did we
want with the Philippines I know I know
yeah except to have trouble with the
Japanese yeah 50 years later
yeah but the manifest destiny I think is
is is one of those characteristics of
the Americans that we have to be careful
of that we don't misuse it yes that we
do use it to better mankind absolutely
absolutely
it can turn into bullying it can turn
into mistaken Wars yes very easily it
can turn into going into places that we
shouldn't go into your life for the
wrong reason Isis okay twin will hate us
then that's right that's right you can
think of us as you said bullies
absolutely I'm trying to impose our
system as though we know what's good for
you yes exactly you don't like it we're
gonna shove it down your throat
right right right exactly so it's
something we have to be very very
careful of and it's something that we at
the same time we do have to be a very
strong nation on the very strong
presence on the world scene so it's a
very delicate issue now you mentioned
the Mexican War yeah which really
terminates this period the other
what that was all about well there were
Mexico at that time own Texas and our
exxor colonized Texas in most of
California and what is now New Mexico
and Arizona and several other
territories that are currently states of
the United States and so there was an
effort on the part of particularly
southerners but some northerners as well
to try to use manifest destiny to take
over this territory that people on the
East Coast believe it was it was rightly
part of America and indeed
geographically it was part of the North
American continent so it seemed natural
that we would take it over and so there
was there was a movement under Polk and
then you know Polk and Tyler to organize
a war to annex Texas you know Texas as a
state to customer always ready to buy it
that's right here's our money of you and
they say no no that's right that's right
yeah we were ready to buy it but they
didn't listen to that and so we felt we
had to attack and indeed we ultimately
did a Winfield Scott actually took an
army all the way across Mexico and
captured Mexico City the same time you
had battles in Texas for Texas
we had battles in California and in
Mexico ultimately we we won the war but
it was a very divisive war because it
opened up all these new territories in
the West and the question is what's
going to become these terrorists or
territories that are they going to
become slave territories or free you
know so the whole it really exacerbated
the whole issue of slavery in a
brand-new way and in a way this gives
rise to the Republican Party and Abraham
Lincoln because they arise to try to
prevent that yes from becoming a slave
territory well in Congress David Wilmot
yes traduced the proviso yes which said
that would be no slavery yes in the
a territory that right we obtained from
Mexico right and that that alone could
have brought about secession
yes oh yeah I could have absolutely it
never passed the Senate but so it it
never really went into effect but it was
a very very divisive proviso yes and it
gave rise to so many tensions is these
escalating tensions between the North
and the South that eventually leads in
1861 to the Civil War right the War
Between the States
in fact the southerners did meet in
Nashville in 1850 to decide whether they
were going to stay or not than they were
waiting to see what Congress would do
yes Wilmot Proviso it always paths
passes the house the house not the
Senate that's a defeat that's way in the
South has yeah stronger voting power
yeah and the compromise that they worked
out largely I think the efforts of Henry
Clay yes Davis ten years for the North
to develop its industrial power so that
it could finally overwhelm the south
yeah without the compromise of 1850 it's
possible that if there had been a war at
that moment this earth would have made
their rights into this house would have
done done well I think it probably might
have even defeated the North attacked
the decline I'm convinced of it yeah
yeah yeah and the other good thing about
it it gave us 10 years to find Abraham
Abraham Lincoln ancestors they didn't
have any leaders no no they didn't even
really have I'm talking about the north
they didn't really even have an
organized anti-slavery party or really
or I mean they had the Whig party but
that was I mean it was very fragmented
at that time yeah I'm talking about in
the early eighteen fifteen you have the
Free Soil party that's right the Free
Soil party right right
but yeah exactly but that didn't do very
well in the elections at that moment now
later of course in 1854 with Fremont it
did a little more than they all
into this new posilutely yeah Republican
Party but we got a ten year break there
that allowed us to gain Abraham Lincoln
base yeah and look over the presidents
that we had Malad film that's right
Franklin PS there James Buchanan yes yes
these are all week lead week need
compromisers but at least they kind of
kept the Union going and some kind of
although without nothing would take a
moral stand on slavery whatsoever and
everything was cooking up to allow
Abraham Lincoln to come to the fore and
the Republican Party and and then we
know what happened after that but you
know even during the Civil War it wasn't
totally guaranteed at all moments that
the north would would win even during
the Civil War there were there were even
more yeah it took four years yes
absolutely
not until Lincoln finally found a good
general and right right who was
determined to grant and Sherman
absolutely yeah and with the South
seemed to have all the really good
that's right y'all absolutely yes
Winfield Scott was still alive and he
was a Virginian yes but we're robert e
lee said my country is virginia yes
Winfield Scott said my country yes is
the Union yes yes and that's what they
talked about
the Union the Union Union he's with all
these sovereign states that had come
together that's right they had to remain
Jackson always said it was not the
states that joined it was the people
that's the way that Jackson looks
forward to Abraham Lincoln because I
think that fundamentally both of them
were devoted devoted totally to the
Union yes they respected the states but
over to the American Union and that's
what in a way makes them glorious